five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast we got two very
special guests in the house I got to
tell you right now this is two of one of
the funniest [ __ ] groups on the
internet YouTube just comedy in general
I know these cats were very [ __ ] a
long time a very very long time if I'm
one of the only few black people I know
anything but we got dorm Taemin in the
house two out of three we got an
Emmanuel and Mike [ __ ] David
David thank you for having us man
yeah I mean I've been trying to get you
guys on for a minute it was funny
because I'll contact him Roman Rome's
like I'm out of town to go on the go
Rome know I didn't know Rome was [ __ ]
fat back in the day oh that's why Rome
is so humble right now you know he's a
hands like you would think like that he
would be out here like but him at humble
because he used to be he always knows
it's like ten cakes away that's the
great thing about the transformation
though and I think you're gonna get to
that point you're getting to that point
but if you were formerly fat in any type
of way and you felt both insecurities or
you formerly ugly and then you become
beautiful usually those people are the
coolest people yeah your balance I think
I believe so I mean maybe some people
get ego get our control right but if you
start looking at your best later on in
life I feel like you're almost a better
person I mean I didn't even know I was
fat so like for me I just thought I was
good-looking the whole [ __ ] time so
it's like when I start gear like if I
start working out and then I see a
picture of me when I was a cameo demo
skinny but well I'm skinny I'm like I
look good everybody talking about yeah I
had like the highest self esteem ever
like the only person that could check me
was my fiance so she was the one and I
told this before she was she was the one
that got me to realize I was fat because
I was the fat girl that was sit and
judge other fat people and so I would
sit there and look at these [ __ ]
disgusting [ __ ] you know and
she would just look at me she'd be like
yo bro
but you're you're the fattest
[ __ ] I ever seen in my life and
I'm like [ __ ] wrong with you
what are you talking but age too because
you start my knee started clicking you
know I was trying to play ball in my
[ __ ] so you never felt down about
being fat as a kid I think when I was
younger I did but then after a while
like you kind of have comedy to really
just balance all that [ __ ] out right
yeah and so after a while you start
feeding into your own [ __ ] yeah so
like I just like oh I'm big but I play
ball I'm right I'm fast for a big guy
and like I like surprising people you
know you start like I got attribution
you're fat yeah like you would you
justify a lot of things especially
because a lot of your friends they look
if you have good friends they'll gas you
up for no [ __ ] reason like you know
you kind of fast for a big guy and I'm
like you shouldn't have done that
because the seed in my head and I'm an
athlete dude you know I mean your
friends I remember saying yeah but we uh
yeah when I when I when rone told me he
was fed I was kind of shocked I was like
damn you you just would have never
guessed
oh yeah man he worked hard for it to him
and he put into work we've seen it I can
see it Isis I still see it in them
I gotta look at Rome and I'm like I see
the fat guy yeah very good
what's the word gulley like like the
Jamaica came out in this man inside it's
funny cuz you know when we were because
we did that show joke me off and so I
guess like everybody on that show so
prior to that I was I was shooting an
indie film so I didn't get to go to
rehearsals right but during the
rehearsals that everybody got this pitch
deck I didn't get the pitch deck so I
didn't know who was gonna be on there I
found out Roma's gonna be on there on
the day I was fashion that's how it
usually happens with us like last night
at one time I think when we first came
to LA Tracey Edmonds flew us out for
something and you were there I don't
know what we did you and cam yeah yeah
we filmed some like dinner scene it was
she had her alright you network
that's what that's what launched our la
life honestly is that um her network
yeah cuz she moved her her funding that
network started to show with us and she
gave us funding to do a show and we use
that money to come out here and and
start a life yeah we were debating
whether we were gonna yeah cuz we were
like yeah where we gonna live and her
and a lot of us for the most part we're
like [ __ ] it like if it's a one-bedroom
we gotta sleep on the floor next to each
other that's what we got to do for the
first year we were Brady like we were
gun ho ho and then that just kind of
came out of nowhere I was like oh sure
see Edmonds wants to buy
she bought like ten clips of ours off
our YouTube like yeah like she says she
license some stuff off our YouTube and
then also she paid us to do to write a
cooking show for right and featuring a
cook which was so random but it was like
we'll take it of course we do know but
yes so that kind of contributed us to
coming out here and that's when we that
was we met you before that it was
because y'all were visiting to come find
a house and we did something with him
well he was at the Tracy hasn't a shoot
because yeah that was I'm saying that
time I don't know that was my time it
through a full screen I think maybe
that's what it was maybe maybe that's
what it was
yeah because I don't remember the origin
because when I yeah cuz a were for for
that's right yeah so then he was like he
always used to talk about David yeah cuz
cuz the funny thing is like he knew
about how poor my attitude was when I
was here right because I was I did stand
up straight up yeah so you know when you
around a bunch of stand ups I felt like
a lot of them are [ __ ] [ __ ]
so I kind of absorbed that type of
mentality and like after a while you
kind of think like number one you know
to my discredit is that before YouTube I
thought I was above YouTube right
because I was I was the youtuber that
came from traditional standards I was
finding out on the stand-up comedy clubs
whatever right were you doing I start
when I was like 16
oh [ __ ] so
when I when I when I came on YouTube it
was like I was about 23 or some [ __ ] so
I us some years under my belt and I
decided to come here and then every time
I met somebody on YouTube I [ __ ]
hated them I was like hmm [ __ ] these
people like they're just like what's the
word I'm looking for [ __ ] losers it's
like I just [ __ ] ate it and but there
was a few people that I click with it
was the JK people who I still work with
today and you guys yeah and I was like
oh these are just normal human beings
because a lot of the youtubers at the
time they just want they just didn't
know how to interact with people felt
like I felt like everything was the you
know either their impersonation of other
youtubers or they're so uncomfortable in
their own shoes when there are other
other youtubers that it makes it awkward
but the thing is when we met David right
yeah I think you were one of the most
genuine people we met and it just
clicked our comedy clicked yeah like I
could sell off it was a mutual respect
because not only just attitudes of the
other youtubers their content I was just
like a lot of them I just was like this
is yeah like you know you know this is
just not necessarily up to par with what
we want to do yeah mm see ourselves
doing but when we saw your stuff it was
like okay this guy gets it he has a
sense of calm and he up the production
right early on yeah you're really trying
to shoot high quality stuff and then any
time you come do stuff with us you would
kill it so it was like I think I feel
like we always gravitated towards the
real ones in YouTube even if it's only
five yo we're always gonna find those
guys you know the funny thing is too cuz
you know when I when people ask me to
work on projects if I don't really know
them like I look at it now think about
it you'd enemy but if you guys asked
ones let's do it we put you in the most
stereotypical role I saw the video again
because it was two of them right yeah
but they're still funny till this one
funny
[ __ ] no I mean this is a humble brag but
our content someone tweeted a bit ages
it ages better ages well and then when
it first comes out like when it's I
don't know I mean we edit we shoot it so
by the time it comes out we're just like
huh what
yeah yeah but like a year later you go
watches like wow this was really rich
man and I don't watch it I don't tend to
watch our content a lot yeah it's
usually like I'm just like right let's
get better with the next one on to the
next one how can we do better in the
next one but the times that I do take a
break in action to go back and watch
stuff
David's clips are [ __ ] hilarious
every [ __ ] time I can't stop the
[ __ ] episode we have so many bloopers
- god yeah but we don't even put those
out yet but we need to default the
[ __ ] the one with the the lean and
Leon one dude like I was leaning Leon
goes to the chiropractor the smallest
[ __ ] dude the [ __ ] x-ray drawing that
was that was during the time though I
felt like I think for all of us - and we
talk about this a lot where it was
really fun always it was fun and we knew
yeah yeah it was super exciting and I
think like at that time
everybody's content was so different and
I got the sample a lot of different
stuff and now every time I go on to a
channel it's like I've seen this already
like I've seen this styled this the way
that you're speaking the way it's set up
it's somebody else's [ __ ] so I like when
I watched you - now I'll be it I get
very I won't say sad but it's hard for
me to find content I [ __ ] with yeah it's
I guess like if we're swimming we're all
thirty yeah yeah I think like the
twenties and up kind of just adapted
this like O's do it works yeah it's not
necessarily like oh let's try to find
something that's different it's just oh
let's do what works yeah I remember even
talking to a younger person and them
telling us like why don't y'all just do
reaction videos I'm like oh you know our
channel doesn't mean as much views as it
used to whatever well I should you just
do reaction videos I'm like but that's
not what we do yeah yeah yeah so it's
like they don't even process the fact
that oh you're trying to do something
just do something that's popular and
it'll get views I was the big deal but
that's the best the thing about that too
is though there's a reason why a lot of
these younger people who are on media
the only last three or four years
because after a while you can only steal
so [ __ ] much
there's everybody's seen all your tricks
so when it comes time for people to
innovate and they got to do new [ __ ]
they're fresh out right all right I
think for us like we've been able to
expand outside of just YouTube because
of all the the skills that we developed
yeah right and it's you know to their
credit like I'll catch myself sometimes
too like for example like reaction
videos right it's funny that you mention
that because there was a point where I
was like you should just do reaction to
it do it throw some [ __ ] pies in your
face prank people do some [ __ ]
and because it does it does start to hit
you a little bit yeah it makes you feel
the way when you put out something that
you work hard on and it doesn't get as
much as it should as you think it should
you're just like what am I doing this
for mm-hmm cuz at the end of the day I
even if it wasn't for the money I at
least was doing it for the people's
reaction I love that I got yeah now I'm
not I'm barely getting that and the
money still sucks you kind of question
yourself but then that's got a dig
deeper and be like what is this r1 my
one day hope that 10 years from now
someone's gonna watch this and hopefully
it makes them do something great I I
really do believe that a lot of the
stuff that you guys were doing was way
before its time like you guys were
innovators right so a lot of the [ __ ]
that I see now and I'm like that's some
old-ass dorm paper [ __ ] you know what I
mean but let me we say it like what we
wanted to do in a way I was our mission
without even knowing that's what we were
doing yeah cuz we always used to stress
they're like yeah we just do it
ourselves like we don't have to wait on
nobody and we would say it to our fans
not knowing that oh they're hearing it
probably there's people out there
watching now who's doing Instagram and
stuff now that probably heard that I was
like shoo okay and don't get it twisted
we still want to be the greatest [ __ ]
comedy group out here but at the same
time to inspire others I mean that's it
like I'm amazing fence
yeah that's an amazing feat like I
wanted to see people I want to see what
genre we're in whatever our craft is
comedy so I want to elevate that as much
as we can some [ __ ] though it's like
sometimes I'll go out to these shows and
I see you know I'll meet a couple of
like newer youtubers and media people
right yeah and they're like yo man you
inspired me when I was younger I'm like
cool let me get $1,000 in my stupid son
of a [ __ ] something dude I'm over here
dying we're trying to create a good art
and [ __ ] you have your watered-down
version of my [ __ ] and there's so much
better yeah but that just goes to show
like also to in this platform you really
do have to learn how to evolve because I
know other people who put their heart
into their art but they just didn't
evolve with the times
and then they're wondering like like for
example this is the best example I'll
give them out it's YouTube musicians
when YouTube first started anybody could
have been a musician yeah you don't mess
you go back to some of these covers that
they're doing they are arguably terrible
singers but they have two million three
to ten million views and so they
expected that type of success but guess
what happens you singing on a platform
out without a NRS without all this other
[ __ ] inspired other people to do it that
were way better than you yeah and so
there was real musicians that came out
and now they're trying to do their same
[ __ ] and they're like well I'm not
getting abused it's cuz you're actually
finding out you weren't that good yeah
competition and stepped up yes is where
you like once the industry found out oh
this is what the power of YouTube or the
power of social media can do everyone's
gonna look Turner I hear you're gonna
get better people so it's up to you
whether you want to get better mm-hmm
and push yourself or you're just gonna
stay there and just you know you're
gonna fall by the wayside
yeah competition is fierce now yeah you
know like music I've seen like some of
these cats were damn like for example
think about this Justin Bieber was a
youtuber man yeah crazy right
YouTube crazy [ __ ] uh Issa Rae Donald
Glover Donald Glover [ __ ] like these
people you know they they made it to the
top and I Lisa raised trajectories
[ __ ] crazy Oh like you talked about
can I get a thousand dollars
we see remember that one time we met
each other
Issa at [ __ ] that sandwich shop my
guys remember that day like it was
yesterday and I know what he should have
[ __ ] planted my seed on you like you
were [ __ ] Oprah dude I should I
should have done something but just
watching so she's a she's amazing man
like just watching how successful she is
and I'll be it like I gotta say man
she's everything she has she deserves to
she was one of those people that I saw
that I was really really rooting for and
then when she popped off I was like yeah
no [ __ ] right just like you very
authentic she's been the same since
we've met it you know I'm saying you
know the relationship we've had with it
like she's just she popped off around
the same time we started right no
awkward black girl I remember I guess mm
we were two years later we were already
kind of like deep into YouTube were
maybe two hundred thousand subs dropping
videos and then she she kind of she we
just are hearing about this awkward
black girl thing one of the guys in the
group can yeah brought it to us and yet
the time I think she was getting like a
hundred thousand views on each episode
and then we just kind of like yeah we
hit her up too and and she ended up she
said she liked our videos as well and
then we just kind of kept the
relationship that's why you sometimes
it's good to be I guess I don't know I
can't find the proper word but to
approach someone first because I you
know a lot of times I feel like we all
like oh I'm not gonna say nothing cuz
they some to me or counter in a way but
it's just like that it was just no
humility
it was just like yo we're fans and then
it ended up being she was fans and I
felt like that was one of the best
things you've ever done relationship is
just being open and free and just being
able to say we're fans not even knowing
if she knew us or not yeah but just
showing her love and then yeah I just
feel like as a good lesson to carry on I
always like show loved II feel like
every industry is like that yeah people
will sit back and just watch you and
knowing that could kind of help they
could probably help your situation but
like you said I mean we're talking more
if you don't ask for something you won't
necessarily I know what you can get not
even ask but just just like the people
in your industry like sometimes you know
I'm sure if you go to something like
shoppers industry and it's like you know
Ralph's in there
food for less I feel like they're not
talking to each other either they
probably got their arms molded but you
know I feel like with us we're able to
work together we can do videos together
we can do we can you know and away from
that we just need to appreciate each
other more you know yeah yeah show love
towards other you don't love towards
other creators it's not oh it's not even
a competition honestly we're not
competing you get a lot of the advocate
a lot of successful youtubers definitely
they do they cross platforms a lot right
so they work with other people and they
try to spread out that way I definitely
did not do that I was like I [ __ ]
hate you get the [ __ ] away from me you
know to me but they liked it was one of
those things that I think was hard for
me like I just like like a yeah we
mentioned this I just didn't [ __ ] with
their [ __ ] yeah so it was hard but if I
did [ __ ] with them I definitely would
reach out I would let's let's work on
something together I'll just be in
something that you do right for example
some what somebody else that did really
great was [ __ ] batch yeah yeah cuz I
remember well first of all I'm gonna
tell you all this [ __ ] story
batch I'm pretty sure you're not
listening this because you're way above
me now you piece of [ __ ] but that she
was sucking funny so when I first met
him what's the name uh that's good yeah
right so he was supposed to be in my
sketch and he said yo there's his young
cat named batch Andrew bachelor you
should work with him and so he would
replace that role for for Wes and so
when I was working on and with this
small little sketch and it was with my
buddy at Josh me and Josh looked each
other late and his mother father's way
better than us he's a great actor
yeah I was like damn he's [ __ ] good
dude like and I remember telling Josh I
was like this dude is gonna be some
[ __ ] big [ __ ] out here yeah because
he was I could tell he was just hustling
and working hard he didn't give up [ __ ]
yeah right and then when we started
working together I was so surprised how
he decided he'd started to develop his
own group and his network because he
started popping off on the vine thing
and so we did this sketch remember even
before that he did something with sha
now he was on YouTube made him he was on
YouTube heavy buy accused dropping skits
but and the quality was actually high
for that time but I'm saying I think it
was like he did something with Shaq that
like a comedy series it was
all those people oh you tubers giving
money to all these celebrities to start
[ __ ] right I thought this fool was
dealing drugs or sunshine I was like
where the [ __ ] are you getting money for
this you're a nobody like there's no
where the [ __ ] is this money yeah I bet
you do what the shitty thing is is like
with people this is the hater of me I'm
like with somebody I really like too and
I'm like god I'm trying to find
something wrong about is batches that
[ __ ] is [ __ ] the size of this mic
yeah looking for something wrong because
the dude was super nice super humble and
you know I'm pretty sure he has his
flaws I don't know what they are yet but
yeah one one thing though I will say
about this [ __ ] lied to me about
his age when I first met him so when I
first met him he told me that he was
like 3 or 4 years younger than me
right and then lo and behold I forgot
what we were looking at but he was on a
pitch deck that I was on and his age
popped up and he's like my age I was
like you stupid son of a [ __ ] so he did
the LA thing when he first moved in lied
about his age and I was like [ __ ] would
you do that boat I can't jump
somebody told me to do that I think my
ex told me to do that she was like you
guys should say you're young I'm good I
see why people do it because I mean I
guess it appeals to younger people and
keep but I want my I want people who
need to know me know me like yeah I
don't need to appeal to people who are
my my in my category I understand when a
girl does it just because my bestest
idol pressure like once you reach a
certain age you're too old or whatever
type of [ __ ] the whole thing is just
like embrace the age man like the
holidays like we all looking good to me
all that matters is your content yeah
like are you good at your craft like can
you are you trying to push the limits
are you trying to get better like that's
alright I guess that one I appreciate
you more yeah like I said when people
don't understand that they're gonna age
like you know that shit's inevitable
right yeah
like that's that's a [ __ ] sign that
thing yeah
- age people die at 20 people die every
day sure every year you should be like
man I'm getting old I'm still [ __ ]
here you know cuz because I mean how
hard is it for us to see like a lady out
in [ __ ] like Fairfax without her lips
done and her [ __ ] cheeks no Botox and
I'm like [ __ ] that don't even remember
what a normal human being looks like
anymore like what's that like what the
[ __ ] is with this constant where beauty
is a set certain way they look like
aliens - I would still [ __ ] yeah but I
see it a lot like you know especially
with some of my like my friends even
like I specifically here in LA yeah I
think because when we're on social media
all we can think about is how we look
and we are perceived man others I think
I think even nowadays I was thinking my
dad like it's just even in music you
gotta be I feel like you have to be
beautiful to sell hmm I feel like you
either you beautiful or you gotta like
have the flyest like that's how you
gotta be free weirdest Oh weird is [ __ ]
well you gotta have you gotta be the lad
or something you can't just be a regular
guy that's Malone ugly type of [ __ ] like
the cutest person is like them there's
no in-between right now it's just like
people just want to see the best of the
best
and I feel like they got mad options on
and on the ground to look at it because
you're doing music right now yeah yeah
so what made you I mean you guys have
always been doing me right right you
actually doing music music now I guess
you just call it that because anything
it's not it's not based on the comedy
album right yeah it's it's a discovering
process every freaking day man and I try
not to take it sick I was even listening
we were listening to y'all on the way
here and I was just like I don't want it
I don't wanna take myself to see I heard
Timothy say something about like you
know just like he just likes things
where people just naturally themselves
it's not taking it too seriously I don't
want to go home I'm studying music like
I actually love to do it and just like
to create but it's a learning process
man every day like every time I work
with some another artists I'm like damn
I got a long way to go yep
like the other day this guy came through
and his voice is just like he was I
don't even know I explained it but his
his singing voice was so on top yeah and
I was just like damn I know it took him
a while to find that because it's like
it's it was so you
to him no one else sounds like that and
I'm just like I'm infatuated now with
just finding that uniqueness in my in my
own voice that's the hardest part
yeah yeah oh I was just gonna say he
used to annoy the [ __ ] out of us oh yeah
yeah all day and night but that's why we
could be a testament to him get better
it was nice oh my god it would be like
2:00 in the morning my phone go out I
did not know what it was music like
that's [ __ ] it's a learning process
it's been one of my most humbling
experiences honestly man like I've
listened back to old stuff and be like
oh I thought he was a mad positive dude
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] funny we seen I
used to tell this man he tone-deaf all
the time people tell me that people told
me that all the time and even now I'm
starting to understand what they meant I
didn't understand what that meant like
what do you mean like I'm singing like
what the [ __ ] right you mean the past
year and a half I'm like oh that's what
I recorded yourself in like if somebody
tells myself I was so frustrated like
when I when I decided to get the
equipment and actually sit down and
record and produce myself the first the
first day I stopped and was stopped and
was like okay maybe I shouldn't do it
didn't sound like how I thought I
sounded it oh for sure so hear myself on
the mic I had to I was like oh oh that's
there's my voice right there I'm it was
almost like adjusting just uh fasting
all the time well you know recording
yourself in a booth is [ __ ] difficult
yeah like saying specifically yeah you
could hear how flat helped pitching
right then and there and so every time
we sing we always think that we're on
Keeble we're always slightly a little
off and so when you're on a booth when
you're in the booth and you're hearing
the music all the issues with
you could actually hear every note that
your [ __ ] on it so people don't
understand that when you sing in a booth
it's way different when you do something
live so when you do something live and
if you're a great live musician is
fantastic but then also you have like
the acoustics the reverb to kind of
cover up a lot of mistakes I sound great
lot sound way better live my song Braska
another day at this spot and my homegirl
was like wow I love it live I was both
of you do music comedy yeah what do you
love more you know I actually only
wanted to be a musician originally and I
just found out I'm a goofy looking
[ __ ] so I was like hold on
second like maybe I should redo this
because I remember Ruben Studdard
started off his [ __ ] I think it's like
because he was a [ __ ] big ass dude
big ass boy - I was like I'm gonna take
I'm gonna learn from his lessons comedy
and see how that works out when that
music video came out with [ __ ] called
sorry for mm yeah and this [ __ ]
done sorry for 2014 my sorry for mm oh
yeah the name of the song yeah sorry for
2000 years re but sorry sorry cuz that
was a scene in that music video with
this [ __ ] was in a hot tub and I
was like this will displace a lot of
water in that [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
this might not be my [ __ ] but it was it
was difficult because comedy you're just
allowed to be funny and that's really
about it it didn't matter what you look
like you didn't have to have any swagger
whatever you just had to be [ __ ] funny
you know with music it was difficult
because there was just so much I don't
know like I had to think about how I
dress how I looked how I act how I
behaved the live performance aspect was
exhausting making sure sound like
everything sounded right with comedy I
could just grab a mic and even if it was
a little [ __ ] up as long as the jokes
went over it was good and so like the I
think at the time when I was trying to
do stand-up that feeling of grabbing the
mic and making somebody laugh made me
feel good you know and I felt like
the the praise that I got for singing
well was more towards me and it wasn't
this thing where I got to put that
energy back right it didn't feel that
way but that's what music does too but
for me it just didn't and so I decided
to lead that alone and really focus on
one thing because I had this issue of
trying to do everything and I call it
like being the jack of all shits you
understand what that's like so what
happens is when we when we split
ourselves you'll have a half made
sandwich so that's that's that was the
problem so I said hey you know what you
need to cut this [ __ ] out and just focus
on one thing for now and then come back
to it and so now I feel like I've done
comedy for so long okay well let me just
try to find my sound and I found out I
don't have a sound I was like so I
because every time I did music I I kind
of sang on other people's track okay so
and it was just fun for me yeah but then
when I had to sit down and say okay but
even when I do covers right so I did a
cover of summer walkers girls need love
too right yeah and I was like okay so
what's my voice yeah you know how am I
supposed to sing without somebody
telling me hey I need you to sing it
like this yeah and then when I was on
the mic I was like oh [ __ ] this is hard
like this is [ __ ] hard I actually
never figured out what my quote-unquote
sound in sight what's my vibe what's the
tone of my voice how do I want to sing
this [ __ ] because every time I did it it
was based on what somebody else wanted
me to do which was [ __ ] fun and I
learned a lot from it but now that I
have to invoke my style into something
totally different things like you're not
paired you're not copying your what's
the original of you what's the one time
I was recording with my one of my
friends who does music and she brought
one our records to somebody else and I
think I was on the hook in the head of
verse and the person said who are those
artists who are those three guys she was
like that's one guy yeah and she he told
her he's like he needs to find a solid
sound to identify with and at first I
was like but I wanted
everything I want to be the guy that
does all this but when you hear a record
and you hear someone's voice it just
resonates right away when you say oh
that's cardi B look that's so-and-so
it's just like it's part of the brand
yeah so you kind of have to you know
identify with something exactly one can
be like oh yeah that's the hard part
even when we do comedy right it's like
even that we got to make sure that we
stick to what we know really well and we
[ __ ] kill it because sometimes like
when we look at other people's stuff and
we see it pop off we try to do that a
little bit we were just talking about
that because we were saying like well we
going to these pitch meetings what are
we saying to these people besides just
what we want to pitch them are we
showing them are we telling them kind of
what we believe in comedy what are our
beliefs in comedy what is our style
mm-hmm and I feel like it's more than
just saying hey this is our show this is
who we are we got to kind of say this is
what we believe and this is how we
approach comedy and this is our style
this is our our our our voice and yeah
yeah we were literally talking about
like what is if I mean what are we
trying to leave behind because we have
skits and when we started doing skits
this for fun it's just like oh let's try
to do something cool let's see and but
then it came to a place you know let's
get good at this let's let's actually
take this as a craft and take it as
serious as possible and I'm a little hot
what the [ __ ] were we talking about it
happens all the time because it finding
your voice keys yeah finding your voice
so even like in a show we just started a
new show called room noise yeah but we
get to basically pick a topic make me we
just Ruth wrote the new intro to go over
but pick a time where that [ __ ] looks
hard as [ __ ] by the way like I watch all
the episodes no you gotta come on there
that [ __ ] looks so [ __ ] difficult
gotta come on there but this is the
thing with with that show is that I feel
like we're in a place where we're where
you don't feel the pressure of you know
trying to sing a certain way let's just
go in there and have fun
mm-hmm and I feel like that's created
room for people to find their voice
alone if you get to experiment freely a
little more there's no judgments where
we're all comedians and we're all having
fun but we're gonna try to do this stuff
high level
but let's just have fun on it so yeah
that's all I think it's cool for people
who just come on just have like that
phrase and it kind of shows the pressure
like the pressure is relieved because
that's how we create it's like I don't
have to necessarily do as much heavy
lifting because this guy's gonna sing
the hook this guy's probably becoming
something good and all I got to do is
kind of just like come in real quick or
you know it's just like you feel less
pressure and that's kind of how we
create anyway yeah it's like all right I
know when we come into this meeting or
this the brainstorming session someone's
gonna have something the fuel this
little idea I have yeah and then we'll
come up with something greater so I I
kind of I feel like that's what we're
showing to in the process is right and
anyone who comes on I want you come on
you'll see it's just like oh [ __ ] I fit
it right here okay yeah you actually
look difficult as [ __ ] you guys are
[ __ ] no no what the [ __ ] I be nervous
making the beat sometimes cuz I'm like I
don't know if they feel in there I can
see and then I look back and I see a
head Abajo and then sometimes you know
they'll be like can we switch up the
beat used to seeing at night and how
much is sucked that's the beat too so I
remember going to our skits yeah is that
we're looking for that philosophy you
know I'm saying like what is our
philosophy when we approach comedy you
know
and we always and we kind of just came
up with the thing that is we're we're
we're analyzing we're basically holding
a reflection up to the world you know
it's very self-reflective whatever is
going on in the and we showed the
ridiculousness in it we think we think a
lot of things are ridiculous and as a
whole I was asking him like what makes
us do a skit about that what makes us
stop our day and say I'm gonna stop
hurting them do it and write something
go shoot it go edit it and pretty much
take up a whole week of our lives yeah
why what encourages us to do that and
it's because we feel so strongly about
how ridiculous this is that we have to
show we have to say our point somehow
yeah so we that's how we do it so I feel
like as a collective that's our one
thing in common it's like we all kind of
find all these things ridiculous the
other so it's like
all right let's come together and make
something about this and you know that's
like the the cool thing about you guys
is how your creative process works
because
a lot of people in this [ __ ] group
and it's it's just weird balance of when
I watch what you guys do it's um
everybody has a very unique voice which
is one of the biggest reasons why I
think I like that your guys's comedy
group the best is because none of you
are the same mm-hmm everybody's comedy
is different in a sketch the way you
guys act the way you speak because a lot
of the times when I see people come
together they all just kind of reflect
each other everybody's comedy was so
different so whenever I watched the
sketch it was it was new because
sometimes it would highlight you yeah
you'd be highlight or somebody would be
highlighted I'm like this is [ __ ]
dope so it was always fresh for me to
watch people who just kind of still
stuck to the guns but still had a group
mentality with yeah and that's [ __ ]
difficult yeah I think that's from
honestly us just live it like a lot of
people feel like you know they'll ask us
oh you know how can I start a group I
did it like it was so organic we were
all friends like two of the guys are
brothers hymns right and one of the
brothers came and Mike grew up together
since sixth grade the rest of us [ __ ]
met in college you know and and we you
know I know for the most part when I
look at my we are loyal you know I'm
saying oil to each other we want to see
the best for each other
we'll keep it real with each other but
when you're in a group you got to learn
to let go that ego ooh yes you have to
learn to let go of that ego can be a
killer and sometimes if you feel and
that ego can pop up in many different
even if it's just an idea you had yeah
you know and everybody else doesn't [ __ ]
with it you gotta eat that yeah you
gotta just like okay it's not working
now but let me and not only just sit
there and get mad or or you know not
contribute you got to also contribute
right who you got oh yeah keep going
okay that didn't work let me try to
shoot out this one and just let go of it
and you know you got a truck and we
built that trust to where you know I
know this dude is funny I trust in his
in his comedy I know this guy's fine I
know what he brings everybody brings
this and it makes it easier with writing
it makes it easier you know when acting
when I'm you know I usually direct most
of our stuff yeah and I'm directing it
so the communications it's not gonna be
the same if we just had anybody else you
know yeah we know how to articulate each
other so I even when we were doing we
shot a cops parody
where we rest in hot girls and we were
filming in the car and rome was on
camera and like just the stuff we had we
were telling it right you were telling
Rome like you know like take the high
pitch out your voice low but put some
more basic avoid on camera sometimes
your voice changes like that so it's
just like stuff like that that we could
check with each other
to Burke and creeped out but the thing
is even with them and you brought this
up early working with youtubers that
maybe you know you know or not working
with youtubers you don't like or
whatever like I think it's what I've
also found is that it makes you better
to work with them mm-hmm it actually
makes you better to work with people
that you maybe you're not the biggest
fan of but you if you recognize their
talent or if anytime you can work them
in some way and it almost becomes almost
take it on as a personal responsibility
too like I want them to do the best
thing yes I want this thing that they're
in to be the best thing they've done to
inspire them to do more right grown-ass
man dog I was thinking in my mind I'm
just like man if I see this [ __ ]
i'ma slap the [ __ ] [ __ ] like I don't
know what it is it's so funny because
like I have like these old tendencies of
when I was younger right cuz I grew a
bit of not that great of a neighborhood
right and that's just that was
everybody's [ __ ] attitude and mind you
like I wasn't dweeb but because I grew
up in a bad neighbor I was had to
pretend all the time just so I wouldn't
get robbed and then now I just realized
as a dolt like these type of behaviors
are seeking to my [ __ ] personality so
it's like there'll be like these like
Asian group stuff right for a lot of
these Asian youtubers get together and
they're nice people and people like I
always want to tell people it's just
because I don't like your stuff doesn't
mean that I don't like you right it's
like I might like you as a person but I
just don't [ __ ] with your [ __ ] right and
so sometimes I feel like because of the
way my friends are in the way that I
grew up we're very harsh and we don't
take things personal like one of the
most refreshing things that I would that
I've been around recently was actually
joking me off that show that I'm gonna
be on
because everybody was ripping into each
other and everybody was laughing you
know I haven't experienced that in a
very long yeah because when I grew up
mind you if I'm the Asian dude in the
group yeah and there's [ __ ] eight
black dudes I'm gonna get kinda ripped
apart all the time so I had to be quick
real [ __ ] yes and so when I first
moved to LA when people would lightly
clown on each other I would just kind of
be like whatever about it and now I'm
like cool so I get to rip back into him
but then the I guess the level of
insults that I would do would be too
much for them and they would feel a
certain type of way but that's just not
how I grew up I grew up if you say some
[ __ ] it's a free-for-all right so even
now like within like certain groups that
I have right now they'll say a joke and
people are laughing right and I'm like I
could say something way worse but you
wouldn't be able to take what I say so
it's like now I'm just like okay well
now for me I have to learn how to
control this this this this type of
attitude I had enough you know so when I
do that when I'm coming around group and
I'm like oh I could probably use him in
this thing the only things I'm thinking
about is you stupid [ __ ] I was slapped
I feel I understand where that comes
from because same situation growing up
you know I mean that not the richest
neighborhoods or whatever but you know
like even when we came out here I think
we had a very militant mm-hmm mindset it
was like yo we coming out here and we
not to be [ __ ] what we got to stick
together strong don't let anybody rip
this apart you know let's let's let's go
hard told people literally told us
before we came we were breaking up god
yeah yeah there's like oh oh it's five
six y'all oh yeah breaking up come out
here y'all can break up so we were like
on a mission to like prove everybody
yeah and then you feed into it and then
you hear you know the Hollywood
stereotypes of course you know that
these fake-ass Hollywood people bla bla
bla bla bla you know the industry you
know rip you apart you you out to you
out rip you PI's I'm sure you well
switch you out I mean that's how you eat
food or some chili but yes so we came
out here with a very militant mindset
but it wasn't until after time it was
like oh this isn't helping anybody
really contribute we were we're putting
ourselves on an island you know what I
mean instead of you know being a part of
this community and giving back in
because there's nothing that
it's not there's nothing but benefits
that could happen right maybe some
people could piss you off or whatever
but I don't pay attention enough to that
[ __ ] anyway yeah I think that's a the
the right attitude to have you know my
and you know it you know you're honest
with I think that's what people
understand about me too it's like if I
if I [ __ ] with somebody I work with them
hard to the day I [ __ ] die I hate you
I will hate you to the day I [ __ ] die
but I really don't dislike that many
people I say there's like maybe like 2%
of people that I meet that are like that
but if I dislike somebody it's very very
[ __ ] apparent the sign [ __ ] I don't
know it's not sign [ __ ] it's just how
somebody at the [ __ ] chassis has
[ __ ]
there's like Cassidy always give [ __ ] to
and they're not really like terrible
human beings but it's just who they are
how they behave what they talk about
they're in the YouTube space too and
it's funny because one of my friends too
met up with them and they asked straight
up they go yo why does David hate you
hate me why is David hate me how he
explained to him was like is not that he
hates you like he obviously doesn't
think about you he just this at [ __ ]
with you your everything you do is just
it's not who he is as a person right so
and it's like you got to stop talking
about it because the more you talk about
it the more funny it is to him so it's
just like because you have to understand
like data finds things everything
hilarious so the more you think about it
the more he's gonna make fun of it
because of how how much it affects you
yeah bad now you know God [ __ ] maybe
this person really does [ __ ] with me but
I just hate their guts because I
actually met this person back in the day
when we when we first started doing
YouTube and he said something to me that
irritated the [ __ ] out of me because I
saw his content and I thought it was hot
garbage still think it is today and you
know he was like yo you and I were the
same person knows I'm okay now I hate
this guy
okay what did it that's coming out of
love
loves you he's telling I love you and
then he comes through why does he hate
me loves you it's so funny because it's
not even me that just feels this there's
like I can name like 30 people that hate
this [ __ ] guts and he doesn't
realize like how off-putting is it he
has a human being I don't I don't I only
talk about him when I want to joke about
him a lot you know just because he
always comes up in conversation and
though how he comes up in conversation
is by somebody tell me something bad
about it so it just keeps the where I'm
just like oh whatever he's good right
and then somebody will come and say hey
do you know this guy I'm like what what
happened terrible I'm like how many
people can you piss on right so it's
like and it's it's when I look at the
the scope of this human being I kind of
really it's like he's he's doing things
in his mind that he thinks is okay but
it's not so he's socially [ __ ] right
so how he uses people and he doesn't
understand that and how he has always
has an agenda when he talks to somebody
it's it's just very obnoxious right
exactly who you're talking about you
pops
you probably don't but I'm kind of
curious who you will talk about oh they
can't see me right no they cannot but
this is I feel like I'm in high school
let's just type text me that [ __ ] I'm so
curious but yeah when sometimes you just
don't [ __ ] with people you just don't
really [ __ ] with them a lot of
flip-phone know that [ __ ] wouldn't
[ __ ] Motorola RAZR [ __ ] oh man I wish
man yeah but that was that was the
that's like one of those life lessons I
really do appreciate I think a lot of
people shouldn't learn from it's like
yeah yeah nobody
well it's I got stories man I would say
this but I cannot but only because it's
petty to mention this story on this
space because it's none of you know
everybody else's business but I got
stories but but uh yeah I'm definitely
learning to just really start just
putting my my my [ __ ] terrible
sensibilities inside I just work with
people because they do have talent yeah
just because you don't like what they do
per se like here's a great example
people who create different content I
always work with because I like them as
people is this group called Wong foo
right so like them like their content is
way different from mine so [ __ ]
different and I'll be it like my shits I
consider there's like very nice
clean-cut and my shits [ __ ] trash
yeah so when I when I go on their
platform I understand like yo I don't
really like a lot of their stuff because
it's not who I am as a person but
because I like them and the stuff that
they're doing and the message that
they're portraying yeah especially for
like for me as like Asian American
filmmakers I'm just gonna [ __ ] with
everything that they're doing yeah you
know I don't like a lot of their stuff
yeah just because I'm not into like
rom-com [ __ ] you know to me when I look
at this stuff I'm like that's just
[ __ ] corny but at the same time
I appreciate who they are as people and
I'd like already do so no matter what if
they post a movie a film they asked me
to be in something I'm gonna do it
because I like them as a as a person
what they're doing yeah and I'm sure
they appreciate that much more than you
know yeah for sure and you know you know
I'm pretty sure they know this but when
I first came I saw their stuff on site
and I think we were in like one of their
videos viral videos where we held some
[ __ ] it was like a one shot music video
yeah yeah yeah it was it was cool though
I mean it was like it was a creative
like you know that was them using their
diversity car that we need to get one
black person here yeah you want to talk
about a group of Asian people that don't
know a single black person
it's funny because we'll see there's
like certain asian youtubers you could
tell they only kicked it with asian
people their whole [ __ ] life yeah so
when it comes to anything black topic
wise they need to get a black person in
the video they're [ __ ] fresh out they
would find the most light-skinned black
person I've ever seen about a life and
I'm like that's easy I guess I guess I
don't know man we sometimes we have a
problem find a white pen that's easy all
right exactly
walk outside a buddy of mine hit me up
for this film project that he has he
goes I need a funny white person be in
the sketch and I got you went through my
phone not a single white person oh [ __ ]
I don't know why people and I had one
guy and he couldn't use him so it was
like oh [ __ ] like that do you feel bad
about that cuz I kinda sometimes feel
like I don't have another way I feel
like that's why sometimes I'm hungry
white people sure but just even white
people ask friends you know that's what
I'm saying though I mean you gotta be
friends with them to get money with them
yeah it's it's weird I think it's just
some [ __ ] that I we didn't really grow
up with so I didn't grow up around a lot
of white people so I'm not gonna have a
lot of white people friends and also to
like when I went to college that was
actually hard for me because that was
the I mean Sacramento does have a lot of
white people just where I grew up there
just wasn't a lot of white beer so there
was the the hardest thing was was when I
went to college for the first time I was
like damn I don't understand why people
humor at all it's different it is
different it was slower sometimes like
just yeah and it's very there's a lot of
a stri sarcasm yeah and I just couldn't
pick up on it and I feel like sometimes
the stuff that I was saying would come
off as really crass and rude because it
was it was the clowning nature that I
grew up in right and I just couldn't
really vibe with it at all did you ever
even watch any white TV shows growing up
yeah once I look like comedies
I watched comedies oh [ __ ] like king of
queens yeah okay you know I watched
friends later on okay and so I think
watching those shows and the reason why
I started watching those shows was
number one friends was just really
popular and I said
really liking it when I was like 18 and
then king of queens was because I would
I saw Kevin James's stand up and I
wanted to watch a show and his show is
just his standing yeah that was my
introduction and rosanna rosanna was
[ __ ] right it was a game change it to
me Oh vicious I mean I feel like most
black people say this but I didn't know
like poor white people like that oh yeah
like I just saw you know so when I saw
Roseanne I was like oh [ __ ] struggling
but yeah that show was [ __ ] funny
it's uh oh it is she is so funny she's
crazy she's crazy as [ __ ] [ __ ] crazy
man I mean what comedian isn't I mean
most comics that's true I wanna [ __ ]
punch out of youtubers you know my
favorite sitcom of all time was actually
The Cosby Show like The Cosby Show was
something I grew up since I was a little
[ __ ] kid yeah and I had the biggest
[ __ ] crush on Denise geez
I remember watching that show and I
think like the the first episode was the
most refreshing because it was and I
watched it later on as an adult and they
got funnier because it was just
essentially Bill Cosby standeth yeah so
when Theo was in his room and he was
telling his dad this whole I call it the
the white sitcom speak to you and I
think that was the pilot episode yeah I
think it was with the bat right and that
show gets funnier as an adult when I
watched it again and I was like damn
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] hilarious hilarious
and and it really molded my perception
of what I wanted in life too right
because well because that show had a
very powerful woman none was his partner
then Marg you believe was probably more
successful than he was she was a partner
at a law firm right and I know he owned
his own practice but she was she was
everything that you wanted in a woman
that I so I like for me I think I I kind
of attribute what I like in women to
[ __ ] mrs. Cosby yes you know like
somebody who was opinionated that
challenges me all the time and because I
watched that show religiously because I
didn't have that's amazing yeah I don't
watch I didn't have cable so I all I had
was public television and The Cosby Show
was always same thing it was repeated at
all the time yeah I loved it and
anything I didn't I didn't really think
much of it growing up that it was it was
weird to watch two very strong like
black figures that had a great family
life yeah that wasn't doing like hood
comedy yeah you know what I mean think
of it like that you just watched it yeah
it was just a really [ __ ] funny ass
show the funny yeah just the
entertainment family then you gotta go
and start raping the [ __ ] I was like
those kids don't want to ride that laugh
anymore no III remember I defended the
[ __ ] out of Cosby one nice person the
first allegations came out like there's
no [ __ ] way and then witness 76 came
out and outside I think I think he's
been doing it it's just like they just
wanted to shut him down so if I alright
let's bring it out yeah I mean they're
they're stories that I hear from a lot
of people about him even prior to all
the stuff coming out that I just the
reason why I feel like I ignored it was
because it just didn't seem real you
know and I felt like it was hearsay and
you don't want to condemn somebody based
on hearsay because a lot of people could
just start talking [ __ ] and make you
look bad just because they don't like
you as a person so I heard this story
where there was a makeup artist who
basically the makeup artist told the
story about Cosby coming up and groping
her and he verbatim said I can do this
because there's nothing you can do about
it and then you know she would she would
talk about this story and like it
happened yesterday she [ __ ] hates him
[ __ ] hates him and so and I heard
this through somebody also it is hearsay
for me so I we have a similar story this
is not any rape story or anything but
this is just a funny a story we were in
the middle of pitch hang it somewhere
Comedy Central were working with another
writer at the time as older gentleman
and he was a writer that work with Bill
Cosby so he told us the story one time
he
I think it was his first time meeting
Bill Cosby he went to this house he said
this guy has leather floors it's heated
and he walked in you gotta take off your
shoes he said he walked into his office
he said Oh mr. Cosby nice to meet you so
and so he started pitching him this like
animation type thing and he tried to
explain a reference from The Incredibles
like I looks like The Incredibles that
uh and Bill Cosby looked at him and said
son I haven't seen a movie since 1975
because he's blind he was completely I
haven't seen a movie since 1975 and here
this man is trying to explain be
incredible so this [ __ ] animation I
was dying and we bust out during it
laughing during the pitch me and all the
white executives I kind of cracked up
because when you know what caused me
went to jail is [ __ ] I heard the first
day somebody threw jell-o pudding at his
face I was dying
these [ __ ] knew he was coming
to prison and they're like I got the
jello but I got to do something with
this do you think that's like a payback
for how Bill Cosby treated Eddie Murphy
yeah I treated those women I feel like a
lot of these guys every a lot of these
people men with power anybody with power
has done some fucked-up [ __ ] there you
could call them but they can at any time
probably but I feel like you know I
don't know I feel like your karma kind
of does come back to you a little bit
and how you treat people is how you get
treated and I don't even know who no
street Eddie Murphy yeah he treated
mistreated he told pretty much so Eddie
Murphy to stop doing what he was doing
because he don't like some cursing he
starts to vulgar and he said if you
ain't gonna say don't don't I'm gonna
stay and this is back in the day like
when Eddie just was starting to stand up
this yeah I mean he was starting to get
hot and I could have killed the whole
that whole career and everybody that he
Murphy burst off of just like
and he was like that uh towards a lot of
comics who weren't clean necessarily it
was like that was a lot of black people
so was that pick up your pants [ __ ] like
that we got it do better like most well
with it it's all just old and powerful
when you get money to serve age you stop
growing at that age for some people
I got money at 25 I'm not gonna think
anything else like this obviously worked
what I thought I'd be here maybe he
misinterpreted with Bill Kosmas saying
he was like if you got nothing nice to
say just rape maybe the [ __ ] crazy
ass [ __ ] he comes from them like
I mean he used to talk about it and
stand up the Spanish Fly and all this
[ __ ] that they put in drinks I mean guys
were probably raping women knew any
better [ __ ] Elvis Presley's wife was
like 14 or 13 yes something like that
yeah cancel Elvis Presley to that
[ __ ] you ain't cancelling
Michael Jackson I'm sorry such a little
kid that's oh I feel so bad you know I
feel okay for saying this now because
our Kelly is in jail now so but I
thought he was in jail now I don't know
they did arrest them again but I don't
know if it's like finite oh well I'm
listen to his music again so oh yeah
like the artists do you associate them
can you separate the artist from his art
I think I can I think I could do it so
let's say if it was fresh I'd be like
damn I'll Kelly I might not listen to
you for a little bit because of how I
feel but then the moment stepping in
like I want to say I want to support
those songs like those feel-good songs
that don't may have nothing to do with
sex yeah but I feel like even when you
do that you just supporting his cause
his habit yeah he did easy gonna go to
jail like that's not my priority to stop
his music like now I'm just enjoying
music that was put out into the world
once it's put out in the world it's
basically not yours anymore
I mean he's making money off of it but
he still making money off I don't know I
feel the way I'm usually decided to say
I don't good foot but when I hear some
of those lyrics I'm just like oh okay
some of the songs yes I do agree well
all the songs that are about sex
obviously can
the only light young he said I like
young girls nah man no seem down wrong
with a little bump a grind that's not
it's nothing it doesn't say 13 in the
background yeah he had that interviewed
that cracked me the [ __ ] yeah yeah that
was interview of the century he lost it
he is a [ __ ] maniac I was like yo
keep your [ __ ] I was like what huh when
I saw the interview I was like what can
he say that's gonna change people's
minds right now
you only make it worse and when I
started watching just how emotional he
was I was like he had been he has the
emotions of a teenager you know how I
get when they're back into a corner that
was only a pre cuz if you see his even
older interviews but he was like I
forgot what it was in the doctor's oh
you talk about the one where he was like
do you like teenage girls and we say
teenage his PR person was like no higher
self in the head also a PR should never
work again in the dentistry yeah my
either that or like you convinced a
career suicide working with our Kelly
it's like who wants a work but you have
to do it you you you like teenage girls
how old is a teenage like that is the
wrong [ __ ] answer [ __ ] did you see
what happened with his lawyer nah look
they asked this lawyer
I guess his lawyer went on the news oh
my god you know this is a job I have a
and as if ball counts arcade and I get
the the interviewer asked them would you
leave your your child with our Kelly he
said no he couldn't
I mean honestly who's able to say yes
I'll leave much all right
okay no you just can't honestly say that
that's what you're you're even if it's
just
in accusation right I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm not leaving y'all that documentary
was literally a documentary about the
worst human beings on earth because
everybody [ __ ] knew and they just let
it go I was like and they were trying to
make it sound like they were victims
okay wait a victim Road you knew he was
raping people and you're just like
that's it that's killing people I think
when they're doing bad [ __ ] if they get
away with it for long enough it just
becomes like always justify it
you've been justifying it from the
beginning probably yeah I mean even if
you felt a hint of this feels weird
yeah but then somebody smooth talks you
or you're just weak you know you you're
not you know in and then you just go on
about the day they say this fool would
be patrolling around like junior high no
no he was gonna McDonald up and pick up
little junior high school girls and talk
down there this is like when you got a
joke he went back to the macmannus you
see how hard it is to write sketches he
already is already doing it Trump's
already doing it he's doing it like you
can't write better than this I'll get
roast that's what it sounds like
how the [ __ ] how do you just I can't
even write [ __ ] like this man it's so
[ __ ] funny like who patrols a [ __ ]
McDonald's dude like what human being
does that [ __ ] did you guys did you guys
also watch that Michael Jackson [ __ ]
though right the first ten minutes and I
turned it off you know the newest one
right yeah there's like but I watched
the whole interview with Oprah mmm Oprah
interviewed them right after the doctor
can I did see that those with the guy
yeah and that made me because at first
when I first watched it the first time I
was like I'm turning so this is [ __ ]
one because I felt like they were
fantasizing about their accuser yeah it
was almost like when he came into the
room it's like there was a glow behind
him and I'm like this is the guy you
taught my best you gonna tell me just
that right but I don't care how good I
thought a person was if you raped me it
coming on that bed a documentary
[ __ ] this like first time I met him he
looked cool but [ __ ] him you know I
don't care like my emotions are gonna be
what it is so I felt kind of turned off
I felt like they were just like trying
to come up off of it
the funny thing was like [ __ ]
sometimes like when I watch these things
and I know I'm supposed to be sad I'm
like damn I must be really [ __ ] in the
head cuz I left throughout the whole
part I was in tears laughing because it
was Wade Robinson talking about he said
Michael Jackson he made me go into a
corner spread my butt cheeks and he
started masturbating me he had you go to
a corner which is very specific yeah
spread your butt cheeks he didn't touch
you but he was just like that's what I
like they just started jack it up on the
spot I'm like this is some weird [ __ ] I
feel like for guys like Mela station has
like a shelf life for you you just gotta
walk that [ __ ] off after if you 35 that
happened when you were you know five or
stronger now you're better now
rape affects males the breath affects
males the same way [ __ ] that man I had a
dude like he tried to you bring another
rape you try rape me he was like I was
like five or four years old and we had a
bunch of kids over at my apartment or so
I don't know what was going on I forgot
but there was an older kid there and he
kept talking about sex and I didn't know
what sex was at the time but he I
remember him pulling out his dick and
asking kids to touch it
what the [ __ ] yeah when I was like this
I was like five years old and I just
remember seeing that and and and some of
the kids were going touch it and then I
remember running back downstairs and
telling my mom that they're having sexy
upstairs at a lesson I was never saw
that kid again it was like we just had a
bunch of kids in our neighborhood over I
don't know if it was we were playing
games or something or it was like a
function now I don't know how I remember
but it was it was Marcus use now compare
that to get your butthole touch but yeah
you know I feel like you just have a
stronger mental fortitude than other
people do man because I'm your comedian
I'll be real don't like I feel like I
would be more like you though cuz
there's a like a lot of fucked-up [ __ ]
that happened to me as a kid and I just
kind of walked off yeah you know but
that could also be because I had
good parents too they kind of help me
out in that type of sense as well but
definitely there is to this thing where
if a guy gets raped they usually keep it
[ __ ] quiet they do somebody [ __ ]
the I'll give that to the [ __ ] great
yeah oh yeah you know you would just I
would just be on this podcast and you
guys are talking about how [ __ ] up
rape is and I would just I would agree
with you I'm sweating throughout the
whole day my shirt B turn into a native
dark navy blue that's the hard part for
dudes right yeah like I mean it's
difficult for everybody seven guys came
forward that means a million guys feels
like you lost you lost the fight like
how do I let this happen and then
there's the thing is you don't think
anybody's gonna care you do then you're
you know just being a guy you
automatically put in the power position
this is weird they soon I don't know how
this conversation came about before but
somebody asked it was a it was on this
podcast they go which Cooper had a
second dick go get [ __ ] in the Alomar
if you had one choice if you were in
prison
options I don't like to answer
that's nice no end up dying because I
got fight I just got fight bro so we had
a I had a buddy who went to put he
wasn't gonna get raped or anything like
that but there's like options in prison
work cuz I've never been to jail I don't
know what that's like I just know for a
fact if I do go to jail I'm [ __ ] like
I'm I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm hard out in
this world right I get to run away if I
want you I'll talk all that [ __ ] yeah
but that's depending on the size of the
human being that's you know but in
prison it's a different type of thing
but he said that he the moment he
stepped in he goes there's a couple
things that you have to do number one
you have to join a group or your [ __ ]
you just [ __ ] and it's a race thing but
this is my thing with this man like how
old are these rules because I feel like
jail probably has progressed since then
gram with TVs in there jail so my guys
in jail with phones TVs like life I'm
not saying jail is no [ __ ] campaña
wanna but I'm just saying like you know
I don't know if the same rules if I
people change like just this society
yeah I mean you guess it's nah I was a
consciousness
in through the [ __ ] ass or whatever I
secure in through there or like the
[ __ ] like well my friend said when he
went to jail like he you basically pay
the security guards or whatever or the
[ __ ] what do you call them do
whatever whatever and they get paid
through family members and they sneak
you in a [ __ ] cell phone and that's
how you get your [ __ ] and that's how he
got his cell phone because I saw his
picture pop up on Facebook when he was
in jail I was like so prisoners aren't
just allowed to have absolutely not
that's not supposed to have it so uh
these how about TV well it depends on
the type of jail that you go to right so
there's like there's like satellite
jails so satellite gels are of people
who number one it depends on what their
sentence is right so I have a friend
who's in a satellite jail right now
because she snuck in like I don't know
like 50 or 70 pounds of cocaine or some
[ __ ] like that [ __ ] is wrong with you
but she basically got caught
transporting [ __ ] so she was a drug mule
you know and so what they do is they get
a lot of young people to do this for
them because they'll have to take the
rap for them how old she I was dating
her at the time she was like 20 yeah I
had made great choices she was 22 or 23
at the time and she basically got caught
on the way and they were they were
monitoring her and tracking or the whole
time and so she's in a satellite Jail
right now because number one she did
community service she did all the stuff
it was like a first offense and in a
satellite jail is basically how I see it
as that she might she might argue with
me on this after she gets out but it's
like it's like jail college campus right
that wreck time you got TV you know it's
a lot more comfortable and you and you
develop skills after you come out of
jail
okay so there's satellite channels like
that and there's also white collar jails
and blue collar jails right so why
college else are people who do like
stock market [ __ ] right and that's like
the TV [ __ ] that you're talking about I
call it Martha Stewart jail so but
prison prison is still prisoner in
[ __ ] prison because my acquaintance
my uncle was he was an educator in
Folsom Prison one of the most scariest
jails in the United States and so it's
still real out there so it's [ __ ]
crazy so when when my buddy went to jail
he said that he had to join a
quote-unquote gang which is just Asian
people and even then when he was there
and that was his safe zone within that
year they were training him to fight one
of the other new inmates it's just for
fun like cockfighting [ __ ] so you're
just like a little [ __ ] and a [ __ ] in
jail
so could you imagine what happens to
people who are like child molesters so
there's like a there's like a hierarchy
child molesters are the lowest of the
low because people would you'll have
kids yeah and so when you're in there if
you're a child molester you're pretty
much fun like you you're basically
fending for your life at that point
every [ __ ] day and you might as well
just be in solitary confinement because
somebody's just gonna come out and kill
you so and then the highest people up
top or cop killers they're like the most
yeah they're like the most cuz so that
hierarchy is so [ __ ] crazy in prison
I just know for a fact for me can't
survive if I'm go to jail just kill me
yeah I'm soft there's this weird phobia
of jail even within our here
I mean I'm just saying like don't you
feel like yeah I mean it is real because
of you know who we are our skin color on
top of your skin cover - I mean well and
weird app where you're from - yeah but
you know I just I feel like there is a
phobia amongst a lot of people - that
like I don't want to go to jail when I
don't know if that should be on the top
of our mind that's the thing it
shouldn't but it's it is a realistic
fear that is ingrained and constantly
reminded of it's like even with little
[ __ ] like driving like I'm always mate
when you get pulled over Oh scary [ __ ] I
got one mom I don't even like like my I
was with my girlfriend my girlfriend was
over the house other night she's like
let's go walk there's like 9:00 at night
I don't walk at night I was I don't walk
in my neighborhood even though it's not
even because what I'm good I'm not gonna
do anything yeah yeah if something
happens in this neighborhood you might
be billing for and they're looking for
somebody right is a black guy walking
what do
that's [ __ ] see that's what should I
be thinking of it's like I'm gonna mind
my business and walk and just be much do
my thing but someone's gonna have
something's gonna happen please gonna be
looking for somebody and I'm gonna be
walking and it's gonna be like I don't
think it's gonna end well yes are you a
woman was right as soon as they say that
you're me I'm just gonna be like all
right man let's just talk about
that's what we need to start off with I
didn't do [ __ ] when I when I get pulled
over [ __ ] I get I get super nervous and
sometimes like it's funny because I
think you know my parents own a black do
supply store I grew up in a
predominately black neighborhood I
forget I'm not black like I get pulled
over and I'm like I'm like teetering in
between that line of not white and not
black I'm like can I say some [ __ ] did
this cop and get away with it I might be
able to but I'm not gonna test the [ __ ]
cuz we're like this weird medium right
it's like you are somebody who is ethnic
or color but the way like why people
look at asian people versus how they
look at black people are two completely
different things so it's like this weird
space that I'm in because when I grew up
in Sacramento it was such an odd thing
because I always felt like I didn't know
where I belonged right so it was I I
went to like a predominantly black
church growing up when I was like 15 and
beyond
before that went to a holy Korean church
and then my parents owned a black be
used or my best friend's black but I'm
still nicly Korean because I wasn't born
here and there was his weird part where
I had this store and people didn't
understand who I was or where I stood on
a lot of these topics or issues right so
it would be this weird part where it's
like you're an Asian dude you own a
store in a mainly black neighborhood and
you're rich but they didn't know we were
poor as [ __ ] and so it created this
weird distance right because I was poor
they were poor we're all poor but they
just see the Asian business owner and
they go oh you're [ __ ] over you're
kicking off our [ __ ] right people and
I'm like yeah I don't even know you
arguably probably have more money than
me because my parents being
asian-american they're too pride to even
take government assistance so we just
had a distractor [ __ ] our boots and
just [ __ ] deal with that [ __ ] and so
it was such a weird spot for me as a kid
because I just didn't know where I
belong it's like I'm [ __ ] hated here
and I'm hated here too
so I say well what am I gonna do at this
[ __ ] war right yeah and he caused a
lot of like racial issues especially
after like the Latasha Harlan [ __ ]
happened you know when she was killed by
that Korean store owner when I was in
there yeah right she just had a movie
yeah we basically highlighted and that
was my whole experience in that film
it's like where do I really belong so I
wasn't and then when I came out on
YouTube right and you know when I speak
I don't hear a hood twang at all I think
I'm trying to talk as wide as possible
in my opinion but it's just in there
I don't know how to like completely take
it out not that I really care - right
yeah and the only reason why I did try
to take it out was when I was trying to
get jobs I didn't get hired because they
didn't want people to be in sales
talking the way that I speak and so when
it became very apparent that people
didn't like the way that I spoke and
even now you'll scroll through some
comments and like look at this Asian guy
trying to sound like a black person and
I'm like damn this is what oh what the
worth of what the [ __ ] am I supposed to
do it shouldn't matter honestly like I
feel like Asian people and black people
man we really like each other
Oh weird cultural like if you take from
each other all the time like we love
Asian tattoos well so does everybody
like like yo remember when it was the
hottest [ __ ] ever like every [ __ ]
black girl was wearing the Chinese
dresses and the [ __ ] chopsticks in
the hair right yeah nobody said [ __ ]
with the mone a white girl put like
everybody grew up with Dragon Ball Z now
so everyone I'm just saying like the
culture is just like hip-hop is big
Maria oh my god my kpop is just like
it's it's a monster yeah it's it's a
crazy monster man like but you could see
the influence of a pop you could see I
always say you could always like tell
what cultures you [ __ ] with depending on
what you got your ass beat with right so
it's like as much as stories that we
would tell like my friend would talk
about stories out hanging his ass
because like me too I just got beat with
the bamboo stick with a switch I got hit
with a bamboo stick
I feel like black people in Asian people
you just beat the [ __ ] out of they kid
that was just the [ __ ] that would
connect us all my mom was all about
hands hands put your hands out cuz she
wouldn't she wouldn't want to leave
scars everywhere so put your hands out
but she would tear them hands up my mom
grabbed a broom a couple times my dad
[Music]
I'll tell you my stories do my dad once
so this is the funniest story now but it
wasn't funny then when I was a kid I
used to get I should just I was a
[ __ ] class clown right
so my dad he would uh I remember this
day too so her name was Miss Gil kansan
so she calls my dad to come out to
school and then my dad because you know
we speak Korean and English and she
would just be like oh your son's doing
this and this and my dad's I smiling and
laughing goes oh I'm so sorry
and in Korean he's saying to me to my
ear he goes what when we go home I'm
gonna [ __ ] kill you so she doesn't
know why I'm crying cuz my dad's like
and so he's just talking this mad [ __ ]
to me and I remember I go into the
Eagles go into the house first and he's
just like fuming and when he's mad he
drives [ __ ] fast yeah so he was
driving super fast the house is this are
all [ __ ] clenched up and I'm like
damn he's gonna beat my ass I remember I
walked into the house and it's just dark
he goes go inside he goes inside and I
literally go inside the house and I'm
going to the living room I turn around
and I [ __ ] office chairs flying at my
head
[ __ ] office chair my I'm eight years
old you hit me in the head and he just
started beating my [ __ ] ass and it's
so funny when I look at it now I'm like
damn that's that probably was child
abuse
he beat me so [ __ ] hard once that my
whole ass was purple and I couldn't go
to school for a week dog that's some
brutal yeah so it happens it happens
everywhere I felt like people normalize
it more than we do more than we should
yeah yeah I think I think it is the next
generation of kids aren't we're not
gonna beat them as much as we compete
but like for us don't like comedians I
feel like you got a like that's what
makes you funny yeah dark [ __ ] that that
[ __ ] that me a life that you know might
have been abusive some whatever your
[ __ ] was like that makes you funny a lot
of times like the [ __ ] people making fun
of you while you're a kid you know being
different that's them yeah [ __ ] makes
you funny yeah that feel like that's
what makes medians who they are they
they're flipping their pain yeah yeah
very very true yeah that was that was
the yeah I don't know why I don't look
at that I don't go like I hate my dad
for it I'm like damn that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] crazy like super cool yeah I
understand I was like my mom just didn't
they didn't know that's why that's what
she knew right yeah yeah and she was
trying her best to like she probably
scared that I was going to turn out bad
and the pressures on her
the not to not raise a [ __ ] up shop do
you know she's just a better version of
her parents exactly so her she's like
I'm not giving you two as worse as my as
my grandparents or my mom did yeah your
grandma that was probably on Nazi in the
goddamn household you imagine our
parents like I know they used to get it
oh if we're sure yeah like probably in
public in front of everybody and it was
okay oh yeah there's nobody gonna say
stop your dad just pull out a gun on you
I remember one time my mom apologized
for hitting me and it was like she said
sorry I'm never forget that day it was
like one time that came home and teacher
said I was talking because that's his
lesson should I used to do like talking
class like and I was in the closet
getting changed after that day and my
mom came by and kicked the closet door
and I fell and I think the way I fell
and how kind of like sad I looked she
made her like the next day she was like
look I'm sorry you know sometimes you
know you have to stop talking in class
that's [ __ ] crazy my parents had
never said sorry to me once in my
[ __ ] life and a lot of parents never
never I think my dad says sorry to me
once it's only because he [ __ ] up on a
phone number that I gave him his sorry I
was like what yeah but even though he
knew what that word meant and my mom I
have a video recording of her telling me
that she will never apologize because
she says it's not in her she goes I
don't know how to do it she goes just
note that when I'm quiet it means I'm
sorry that's a [ __ ] it's up stop that's
hilarious sometimes you gotta accept
your parents just stay that way did you
ever get beatings by other people oh at
church it was a free-for-all I didn't
know that you could transfer parenting
abilities to another Korean parent to
whoop your [ __ ] ass and so like I
would get my ass beat by people I don't
know in the church and they would tell
my parents what I did and they would
beat you exactly I would get a tag team
I'm like so I got my ass pulled by this
stranger and I'm gonna ask what I don't
she [ __ ] suck dude
I went to boarding school for two years
what the [ __ ] yeah I was a it was you
know underprivileged kids they help out
parents okay you can't take care of the
family or whatever so I went there for
two years and I just remembered my first
year there I was a goofy kid I was
always class clown like I've been doing
the same [ __ ] and I remember one day in
our dorm room in our it was in the
bottom of a building and we're in the
dorm room you know I went to the
bathroom we laughing about something and
doing some [ __ ] I remember dancing like
this and then all of a sudden two of the
kids that are facing me just looked up
and they stopped laughing with me while
on debt I'm like I'm like what's going
on and then I just feel the shadow of
God over and I look back and it's our
he's basically our Hall Father when it
takes care of all the kids on this you
know like the elementary school kids
that [ __ ] and he was this big white guy
from Texas to I mean you would think
immediately he's a racist but I mean he
took care of us but he turned around he
said come here and he took me to his
like they have like their own apartment
area and he told me pull down your pants
and he took that he took out a paddle
whoa straight wooden paddle and this
thing had like I never had like holes in
it that's what that's the wind
resistance it gets where the wind
resistance bro he [ __ ] me up and I was
ready to [ __ ] leave so quick yo and I
remember this wasn't the first night
because I first time I saw a kid get
paddled he told everybody line up
outside of the dorm by like 20 30 kids
and there's one kid I remember he was
crying he was I'm sorry you're gonna
learn the day he told him pulling on us
man he took that paddle but he went
running across I mean he cleared it he
run across he said come back here he
said come back he's crying and [ __ ]
holding his ass he said uh hit him again
indoor track
but yeah wow this fool up like a little
toy car like today you're gonna get in
trouble for [ __ ] like that oh yeah I
don't know I don't know like I'm not
really the reason why I don't want to
beat my kids is simply because I'm lazy
man I ain't trying to [ __ ] him yeah to
punish you I feel like there's a way to
talk about there's obviously a better
way to do it but at the same time don't
you kind of create think it creates a
little bit of a backbone for the child I
mean I I think like up to a certain age
I might give him a little tap on the ass
you know flick in the forehead or some
[ __ ] yeah but after a while it's like if
you can't if you can't talk out your
[ __ ] problems at a certain age when
you're when you're cognizant as a human
being then we're gonna have [ __ ]
issues cuz at that point I'm I'll just
dude I'll they'll beg that I'll [ __ ]
beat them because I'll do way worse [ __ ]
[ __ ] mental warfare [ __ ] butt-naked
at your school no [ __ ] idea
[ __ ] mentally scarred the [ __ ]
[ __ ] stop beating me what she did was
she used to make me wear these little
ass shorts you know as a kid right now
so every time I would get in trouble is
just when she stopped beating me shoe
just made me wear these shorts for the
whole week in the same sorts and people
would Mike why wearing the shorts
where do you after that week I was good
for like two years
maybe something like that I might do now
would you go as far as putting it on the
internet have you seen these man I think
that's even more mutilated and then
whooping you can whooping you're gay
yeah I wouldn't ever I've seen the kids
like shaving their shave their head off
and put it online this how you treat
that's too much work cuz I gotta set up
a camera yeah right upload it and title
it grab me a beer
right why is my punishment I just got to
do stuff for you it's like the daddy's
lazy doing all right like I'm asking the
kid I have watched that tag edition I
gotta get I gotta go put them winning
them in this thing but I guess Bri yeah
man we wrapped up now though beautiful
usually this podcast only goes like 50
minutes come on do we go 30 the best
podcast yay guys well before we sign out
tell them what they could find y'all
dorm tainment
at dorm tainment on twitter and
everything you know our youtube dorm
tainment TV and we got this new show
room noise what David's gonna be honest
yeah yes and you just look out for
greatness well check out my album daddy
season brown-skinned music video out and
yeah man
yesterday my G my damn Manuel Richards
just follow us Emmanuel with a man but
uh you could find genius brain on
Spotify podcast any type of audio
platform but you've got a podcast oh yes
comedy Trap House please tune in watch
it check it out and also we got a
patreon for that that you can check out
but listen to us first I think you'll
like it you know and it's not like you
for sure like get on that podcast watch
this [ __ ] some of the most talented
human beings I've ever met in my life
we love you man honestly like if there's
one person we always think of whenever
we have a project something comes along
how can we fit David so into this if you
do somebody slap let me know to peace